what's up valuetainers wait
what's up valuetainers it's gerard
michaels you know me from the pbd
podcast i uh directed mafia states of
america and i'm a nationally touring
comedian and these are valuetaining
questions
[Music]
the money
[Laughter]
no
look coming from the area that i come
came up in
you know i was born in brooklyn raised
in jersey uh the mafia was always a
fascinating topic it was something that
we all knew existed it was something
that we all knew somebody that was
connected in some way or another what
really fascinated me about the story
that patrick uh wanted to tell
was how the mafia
interacted with our government
and how our government supplanted the
mafia in many different industries like
you know gambling for example and uh you
know the ability to to do that without
picking sides just telling a story and
uh you know giving a perspective of a
generation and an america that really
doesn't exist anymore was something that
was really really really attractive
hecklers on stage are are fun you know
managing a project of this size and
scope across you know five different
sets with 50 different employees
it was a challenge i mean it was it was
awesome everybody that worked on the
project was incredible very very
professional but uh
it was it was a challenge for sure it
was a chat you deal with a heckler on
stage for seven seconds you deal with
post-production for seven months
everybody wants to be a gangster until
it comes time to do gangster [ __ ] and
that's i think that that's kind of the
truth of it it's something that seems
really really cool
until it comes time to do it and then
it's like
i don't know i think that it's because
deep down inside
if you forget about the evils that they
do what they they're in control of their
own lives they don't listen to rules
they make their own rules there's
something about inside each and every
one of us that call of the wild that
says you know what screw this i'm doing
what i want to do i'm making my own way
in this world
i don't think i should comment on that
the uh
the similarities are
government
uses
threats government uses force they both
operate off of the threat of force do
what i say or else in the mafia pay me
this or i come and break your knees in
the government pay me this or i come and
take away your house i come and throw
you in jail it's not a volunteer society
these are apparatuses of force and as
such i don't think either should really
exist but that's neither here nor there
what's on your playlist it depends on my
mood you know i i'm a really weird dude
i could have you know metallica i could
go from you know onyx back in the day
old school rap to uh billy joel i'm all
over the place man what's the sexiest
accent i gotta go with the latinas man
you know it's something the girl calls
you daddy it's a little off-putting but
they call you poppy and it's all right
all right
if you could have dinner with any
historical figure who would it be and
why helen of troy i gotta see what this
chick looked like to send two continents
in the war for 10 years if hell and
detroit look like honey boo boo all of
all of history needs to get thrown away
i need to know what helen detroit looked
like to see what the big fuss was all
about what's your favorite movie i think
the best movie ever made was apocalypse
now but my favorite movie to watch is
like predator or demolition man
starbucks or duncan
neither make your own coffee save that
money
music on or off during workouts on
working out with working out with uh
without music on i mean come on what's
what's even the point of that
psychopath
what are you what kind of lunatics
window or the aisle got to be the aisle
man got to be the aisle any hidden
talents any hidden talents i don't know
man i think all my talents are pretty
much on display for the world here
the uh
[Laughter]
damn
now i pretty much i i'm not good at most
things and i monetize the only two or
three things i am good at so i don't
know who do you want to play you in the
movie of your life my ex-girlfriend when
i was when i had my hair long and i was
gaining weight during covert like to say
i looked like if jason mamoa ate jason
mamoa so probably let's uh let's get
jason momoa off of keto and then he can
play my play me in my life story do you
sing in the shower of course is it okay
to take your shoes off on a plane
no
do i do it
no
is a hot dog a sandwich of course
anything between two slices of bread is
a is a sandwich what will people be
nostalgic for in 50 years they'll
probably be nostalgic for a cowboys
super bowl because they still wouldn't
have won wanted in another 50 years
do mermaids have babies or lay eggs they
lay eggs right because wait no
she's a mammal
what do manatees do manatees they lay
babies they lay babies they lay there
they play dolphins
dolphins and manatees
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah it has it has babies
for sure what's your favorite cartoon
character
jessica rabbit
what's the better feeling a standing
ovation in a comedy club or on the
baseball diamond there is nothing
absolutely nothing i could ever compare
the feeling of making contact and
knowing the ball's gone as soon as it
hits your bat you make contact
and before it's like time stops before
you ever hear the crowd before you ever
see the ball take off you go oh gotcha
and then boom there's no feeling like it
in the world dai chainers i got to tell
you from the from the first second i
walked in the door with the pbd podcast
and everything else you guys have been
some of the coolest best people on earth
you know the way that you guys support
us and uh you know i see all the
comments that you leave and now you guys
show up at my shows you drive an hour
away uh it's it's unbelievable
you know who you you folks are and uh
none of this happens without you so i
from the bottom of my heart i know the
staff feels the same way we love you
even the people who leave the nasty
comments we love you too because you
juice our algorithm so thank you but the
uh there's nothing like the valuetainers
and we've only just begun baby the
future's bright
you